ANYWAY, PETER, THANK YOU.
WE APPRECIATE YOU BEAMING WITH
US.
IF HERE WITH REACTION FROM A
FORMER SENIOR ADVISOR TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP KELLYANNE CONWAY
AND JOE CONCHA.
KELLYANNE CONWAY YOUR REACTION.
>> NOW YOU KNOW WHY THEY DON'T
LET BIDEN DO THESE CONFERENCES.
HE IS OUR GAME WITH REPORTERS AT
HIS POLLING NUMBERS, WHICH ARE .
JUST TODAY, MORNING CONSULT
"POLITICO" POLL CAME OUT WITH A
REPORT CARD, NOT JOE BIDEN'S
REPORT CARD ON JOE BIDEN, IT IS
AMERICA'S.
37% GAVE HIM AN F, COMBINED 31%
GAVE A OR B.
IT TAKES AN AWFUL LOT FOR
AMERICANS TO WANT TO FAIL THE
PRESIDENT AND THE PRESIDENCY.
WE HAVE LIVED DURING THESE
TIMES.
WE WANT THE COUNTRY TO BE
PROSPEROUS AND SUCCESSFUL AND
INTACT AND SECURE.
AND PEOPLE JUST DON'T FEEL THAT.
SO FOR TWO HOURS TODAY,
JOE BIDEN REINFORCED WHY HE IS
AN UNPOPULAR PRESIDENT.
WHY HIS POLLING NUMBERS
ACCORDING TO THE GALLUP POLL,
46% APPROVE, 56% DISAPPROVE,
AFTER ONE YEAR THE LOWEST ON
RECORD THAT SHE HAS LOWER THAN
DONALD TRUMP'S, WHO DID NOT HAVE
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA PUSHING FOR
HIM, COVERING FOR HIM, AND OF
COURSE VOTING FOR HIM.
I WOULD HAVE ASKED THE MEDIA
DIFFERENT QUESTION, WHICH IS DUE
ANY OF YOU REGRET VOTING FOR
HIM?
TO ANY OF YOUR REGRET COVERING
UP STORIES ABOUT HIS CORRUPT
SON?
DO ANY OF YOU REGRET NOT PUSHING
HIM MORE ON THE POLICIES AND
ISSUES AND FORCING HIM OUT ON
HIS GROUNDHOG DAY BASEMENT WHEN
HE WAS CAMPAIGNING OR NOT
CAMPAIGNING?
BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT WE HAVE AND
IT'S A SERIOUS POINT THAT HIS
NUMBERS HAVE CRATERED AMONG
INDEPENDENTS, EVEN CNN HAD TO
ADMIT TODAY, SEAN, THAT AMONG
INDEPENDENTS, JOE BIDEN AT THIS
POINT A YEAR AGO WAS OVER 60%.
HE IS NOW AT 33% APPROVAL.
AMONG DEMOCRATS, HE WAS AT 98%
ONE YEAR AGO.
HE IS AT 82%.
THE ATTRITION IS NOT JUST RIGHT
WINGERS AND CONSERVATIVES ARE
PEOPLE WHO DO NOT LIKE FOR
JOE BIDEN.
IT IS ALL
SOME BELIEVE HE ISINCAPACITATEDR
NUMBER BELIEVE HE IS
INCOMPETENT.
AND I THINK THE INCOMPETENTS
MEASURE IS THE MOST ADORABLE ONE
BECAUSE IT IS A REFLECTION ON
THE ENTIRE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
UNTIL WE CHANGE THE POLICIES AND
UNTIL WE CHANGE THE PRESIDENT,
THIS COUNTRY IS NOT GOING TO GET
BACK ON THE TRACK WHERE THEY
WERE.
THEY MISSED THE POLICIES, THEY
MISSED THAT AMERICA FIRST AGENDA
AND ACCOMPLISH MATTHEW RAN
THROUGH BECAUSE PEOPLE FELT MORE
SECURE AND MORE PROSPEROUS.
THEY HAD MORE SPACE IN THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENCY.
>> Sean: JOE, ON TOP OF THE
UKRAINE DISASTER THAT IS NOW
UNFOLDING AS A DISASTER, YOU
KNOW, PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID
SOMETHING TO MARK LEVIN WHO
INTERVIEWED HIM RIGHT AFTER THE
PRESS CONFERENCE.
I ACTUALLY PREFER THAT HE
SUCCEED.
YOU KNOW, HE'S BRAGGING ABOUT
HIS ECONOMIC NUMBERS BUT THE
AVERAGE AMERICAN HOUSEHOLD IS
PAYING $5,000 MORE A YEAR
BECAUSE OF HIS INFLATION THAT HE
CAUSED.
UNLESS HE REVERSES COURSE, THAT
IS NOT GOING TO CHANGE, IS IT?
>> AND WHAT WE SAW TODAY FROM
THIS PRESS CONFERENCE, SEAN, IS
HE IS NOT GOING TO REVERSE
COURSE.
IT IS LIKELY HEARD THE SAME SONG
AGAIN AND AGAIN, WHICH HE SAID
DURING THE CAMPAIGN, AND NOW AS
PRESIDENT.
AND WHEN YOU WATCH ANY
PRESIDENTIAL PRESS CONFERENCE,
YOU LOOK FOR WHAT ARE THE BIG
THREE HEADLINES YOU CAN TAKE OUT
OF IT, RIGHT?
HERE'S WHAT I HAVE.
HEADLINE ONE: BIDEN SAYS
REPUBLICANS WILL CHANGE VOTE
TOTALS IF VOTING LEGISLATION
DOESN'T PASS.
WAIT, I THOUGHT THAT SUCH
RHETORIC WAS CHILLING A TAX ON
DEMOCRACY.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES SOWING DOUBT IN
FUTURE ELECTIONS, AND EVERY
POLITICAL PUNDIT OUT THERE WHO
SAID IT WAS WRONG FOR THE 45TH
PRESIDENT WHEN HE DID IT IS
AWFULLY SILENT TONIGHT AS FAR AS
WHEN JOE BIDEN DOES IT AND IT
SHOWS YOU HOW PHONY ALL THE
OUTRAGE ON TV WAS ABOUT THAT.
HEADLINE TWO POLL: BIDEN SAYS HS
ENCOMPASSED MORE IN HIS FIRST
YEAR THAN ANY PRESIDENT IN
HISTORY.
GIVEN THE 40 YEAR INFLATION THAT
YOU JUST MENTIONED OR GIVEN
RECORD VIOLENT CRIME, HOMICIDES,
MORE THAN 2 MILLION PEOPLE
CROSSING THE SOUTHERN BORDER
ILLEGALLY, THAT IS A FASCINATING
CLAIM TO ME.
SPEAKING OF CRIME, DESPITE TWO
HOURS, DOZENS OF QUESTIONS, NOT
ONE, NOT ONE ON VIOLENT CRIME
IMPACTING SO MANY AMERICANS.
I KNOW PETER DOOCY HAD IT AS
QUESTION TWO BUT DID NOT HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY.
SO HERE'S WHERE WE ARE.
THAT WAS AN UNMITIGATED DISASTER
TODAY, SEAN, AND THOSE PRAISING
THE PRESIDENT FOR LONGEVITY OF
THIS PRESS CONFERENCE, IT IS ALL